so welcome back everyone now that we
understand how to use blockchains for
currencies let's look at applications of
of blockchains that are way beyond
cryptocurrencies and in some sense this
is a lot of the excitement around the
space in that we can use blockchains for
many many other things so first let me
remind you that we talked about various
cryptocurrencies out there but in fact
there are many many cryptocurrencies
that already exist so we talked about
bitcoin and ethereum but in fact there
are many others and i listed um sort of
the largest uh out there today
um
so it's quite interesting for example
eos is a potential competitor to
ethereum uh stellar is a different way
of managing the blockchain litecoin is a
competitor to bitcoin with uh cheaper
transaction fees fees tether is trying
to produce a stable uh stable coin so
that doesn't uh fluctuate as much um
cardano has its own um a consensus
mechanism and monero is a very private
uh cryptocurrencies as we'll talk about
in the next segment so you can see these
crypto many cryptocurrencies are out
there they they differ from one another
um in different ways but these are still
limited to currency applications so i
want to talk about um applications
beyond currencies okay so
we already said that in fact um
cryptocurrencies themselves are quite
interesting in that you hold the funds
no one can take the funds away from you
and in fact one of the successful
applications of bitcoin is in fact as a
replacement for gold yeah this is kind
of one of the killer apps um for bitcoin
if you think about it it's much easier
to store than gold all you're storing is
a secret signing key a 32 byte secret
signing key it's much easier to
transport the funds or if i want to give
someone my currency all i have to do is
give them
my secret key or just issue a
transaction on the blockchain and it's
much easier to kind of exchange these
currencies with other
others than it is with gold so already a
replacement for gold is kind of an
important application for for bitcoin
and i want you to remember that maybe in
a developing country this is maybe not
such a big deal but if you're in a
developing economy where perhaps you
don't trust the local financial system
um you know these cryptocurrencies are
kind of a way for you to develop a
savings account um to store the funds
transfer the funds and so on in a way
that seems potentially
you know more more appealing than what's
available to you
there are problems with the existing
schemes one problem of course is the
issue of scaling which we'll talk about
later on the bitcoin network for example
is relatively slow it handles about
three transactions per second which is
much much much slower than for example
the visa or the paypal system as we'll
see later on the other problem is um
there's high volatility in that the the
the price of these cryptocurrencies
fluctuates quite rapidly
but fortunately there are solutions to
both of these um so for example for
example there's something called a
stable coin that tries to address the
issue of high volatility if you're
interested in how stable coins work you
can just basically google this concept
there's a lot of information on how
stable coins operate it's quite
interesting
and worth learning about and then for
scaling in fact many many many scaling
proposals
i'll talk about those actually in the
next next segments yeah so there are
good solutions to both of these problems
and we can expect that um
uh you know at least the replacement for
gold application will continue to be uh
quite successful at least for bitcoin